i wasn't allowed to read them growing up
and my parents were like
we don't want you to become a witch and
i was like well
it's fake we brought together
seven harry potter fans i'm a harry
potter fan i am a harry potter fan
i am a harry potter fan i'm a harry
i'm a harry potter fan i'm a harry
potter fan
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
[Music]
who is the odd one out
i think the best thing to do right now
is say your house and your patronus
oh that's a good idea i'll start with
you okay ravenclaw okay i'm a hufflepuff
and i'm a shrew
hufflepuff and sugar glider ravenclaw
alchemy
ravenclaw red squirrel potter gryffindor
otter i think i was most suspicious of
rachel her and i were the only ones that
kind of came on full
customs because i was expecting
everybody will do it so when nobody did
i was like hmm who's read the books
oh okay perfect okay cool what's your
favorite book
third okay goblin the first one yeah
i'd say the seven person i'd say order
the phoenix
i'm half blood prince so nice okay i was
really suspicious of cameron he wasn't
wearing real hufflepuff gear
he wasn't talking as much so i thought
he felt overwhelmed with the amount of
material we were talking about
what's the spell that hermione said in
the second book when she fixed harry's
like glasses
oculus raparo yes and what boogie second
book when they're
when they're at diagon it's not the
second book yes it is
yeah she does it twice he was like and i
was like
whoa and i so i got kind of like
defensive
excuse me specifically yes that's what
i'm saying okay good catch
for the two ravenclaws what are the
actual ravenclaw colors
when you have seven people one minute is
not enough everything was moving so fast
so it's hard to guess
who else might it be
i was most suspicious of cameron because
he didn't talk at all
sorry i would have voted myself out i
feel like i took one breath and then i
was gone
when did you guys start reading harry
potter yeah so i read the first
book the year it came out so i was in
fifth grade my mom read it to our
fifth grade class i didn't read the
books until seven years ago because i
was born and raised in el salvador so
over there it was
just too expensive for me to get the
books with my first salary i bought my
first
harry potter book which was the first
book my sister was a huge harry potter
fan but i was like a little scared
because i saw voldemort and like is this
like a horror movie
in high school had a really really big
crush on this guy
and he was a big potterhead and i just
wanted to really impress them so i
started reading all the books and i
watched all the movies
like if you're watching this to turn the
video off
i wasn't allowed to read them growing up
and my parents were like
we don't want you to become a witch and
i was like well
uh it's fake hufflepuffs yes
who's your head of house uh it's a
professor sprout
question for the ravenclaws what is your
true mascot it's a it's an
eagle um for the ravenclaws who is our
head of house
you mean the founder founder and now we
need the questions
yeah someone give me a question what was
lulu bagman
known for oh he's the um quidditch
announcer right at the um world cup
i was like oh is that the wrong answer i
asked a question about ludo bagman who's
a character in the books who didn't make
it into the movies
i was trying to see if she had actually
read the books versus just
maybe watching the movies or maybe just
trying to study up my heart is pounding
right now because like
i feel like i read so much fan fiction
that i'm like
yeah i'm like what's cam i need to ask
you about that did you
isolation is a fan fiction about a
budding romance between draco
and hermione yeah of course i read it
it's a classic
and i have a question for you uh why you
didn't bro
besides your one any other like okay
first of all harry potter apparel is so
expensive
i didn't wear any merchandise it
probably like gave
a lot of people reason to suspect me his
shirt was comics related
the mall would for sure have a wand but
what about the rest of the clothes
what's your favorite scene from the
books like something it wasn't in the
movie that's a good question yeah
if everybody read the books then they
should be able to name a scene in the
books that wasn't in the movies
mine is when dumbledore voldemort died
because in the movies he died
as uh like that he had to read it in the
book he died as a mortal man
uh ron and hermione become prefects and
malfoy does too
and then they're like walking through
school and hermione's like harry don't
go picking around with malfoy he's
prefect now he can make life difficult
for you
and he goes wow i wonder it would be
like to have a difficult life honestly i
think it had to be the quidditch final
in prisoner of azkaban because there was
no
that just wasn't included in the movie
oh yeah yeah i really wish that they
include like peeves the poultry guys
throughout the whole like movies like he
wasn't there oh do you guys like snape
state fans yes no i hate his name he
heard petunia he literally got her
hit with the branch and that's when he
like showed effect there's like nothing
in any of the books any of the movies
that shows like that he wasn't actually
all about that life
in both in the books and and the movies
i feel like all
alone he has dumbledore's support i
don't know what i don't like dumbledore
he's a manipulator i don't like him he's
weird was talking so much
he is probably only giving all the facts
that he study
and speaking more so the rest don't get
to talk yeah dumbledore is a manipulator
he is
literally literally like he's turning
away
that'd be good i look at each character
as if like they're people and
dumbledore's background like with his
thing with grindelwald so i feel like
that makes him human at the same time i
can kind of relate to him i'm sorry
we have a tie the tie is between
kylie and intong that means we're going
into a tiebreaker
each of you is going to get 20 seconds
to
state your case i think like everyone
here would know the quote
um at the end of the book when peeves
comes out into like the hall and
says like we did it uh we bashed them
we potter's the one oldie it's gone
moldy
um
i mean i'm a lake potterhead but i
freaking love harry potter i've been to
like all the landmarks i've been to
leaden hall market
i've been to black park i've been to the
elephant house and i spent so much time
there oh my god and i've also been to
harry potter world obviously
i'm just a really big harry potter and
i'm super nervous and i think that's why
i'm like supplying a black outfit
good luck guys
this will be the favorite movie scene
round
each of you will get to tell the others
what your favorite harry potter movie
scene is
and why my favorite book a movie is the
third one but my favorite scene is from
the sixth one when harry potter he drank
felix like the lucky charm and he's just
walking and then like professor
slughorn comes and he's like harry and
he's like
sir when they are at the uh like dinner
hall
and each is eating like in their house
uh tables he started to learn
with the girl that he wanted to go i'm
forgetting her name then he's like i
want a water for this i would start into
that bottle of water
so he goes like you know the water like
street because he's just so nervous
because flooring with her
the first one i just screwed it up so i
was like okay i have a backup
and i have another one had a gift the
book with the sock and he found this is
like
oh master have give them a song in
order of the phoenix the fight between
dumbledore and voldemort
is just crazy like that's the only
reason i really like the harry potter
movies is because it gave me
a way to actually see what i've been
reading since i was 10. it's like a
flashback
of james potter and him like bullying a
snape and saying i'm taking down
snively's trousers i think that's a very
important scene to me because it shows
that
even though it's like something to look
up to there's like flaws in every
character deathly hallows when hermione
has to obliviate her parents
it's so sad it's a very gryffindor thing
for her to do to protect her parents by
obliving them she doesn't even know if
she can get their memories back
the most suspicious person i think was
gracia because she blanked out on
a couple of things
[Music]
i'm not a model
i was really disappointed i went in the
whole effort to like come in a complete
uniform maybe the mall felt like
threatened
and that's why they got me out if you
want to continue playing the game
please raise your hand in three two
one vote one more time in three
two one
kylie mentioned her sister was a big
harry potter fan she could be wearing
her sister's
sweatshirt and using her sister's wand i
started doubting like brian he might be
the least likely option but that would
be like the biggest
gasp moment i'll do one last vote
three two one go
oh my god
what can i say we're magical
one of you guys could be the most
because you guys want it to end so you
guys can get the money
there's no harm in just having another
round i think i feel like we got them
all all three of you guys have given
some pretty like deep cuts the
level of material that we've been
talking about it's too
intense that i think the mole wouldn't
be able to spit out those
facts so easily i want to keep going
because i'm just like
a little bit suspicious and part of me
is like i need to like
have it down to like the last survivors
i don't know what to do anymore
[Music]
so if the lights turned green you guys
went if the lights turned
red the mole is still in the box and you
[Music]
lose
oh my gosh so when it turned green i was
like all right cool we're good
i was like i'm really glad that i made
it to the end i'm very proud of myself
i'm i'm sorry kylie i voted you several
times i was kind of suspicious of you
now i feel bad obviously i was supposed
to because you're like you know so much
i was like odd man that's going to
psych me out well please step forward
and reveal yourself in three
two one
i am a hufflepuff i took i took the quiz
but my roommate is a huge potterhead
i was traumatized by voldemort's face
when i was six in this movie
and that's why i just never went back
considering that i've never actually
read
any of the harry potter books and i only
watched like two of the movies
i think i did a pretty good job i am not
into harry potter and i never will be
into harry potter
i can already hear the haters behind the
screen so you haven't read isolation
i feel so betrayed that you did study
and the fact that you brought a sweater
props to you he didn't he didn't do it
i don't specifically think that you have
to read the books to be a fan
if you do read the books you are able to
appreciate it more i had immigrated to
the united states at a young age
harry potter was like a place of solace
for me a refuge
i was able to be part of something like
bigger perhaps something that is like
magical and like
can take you away or distract you from
like things that you're going through or
like tough things
i think that's why it has like a special
place in my heart
[Music]